They're just entire cabbage leaves, kimchi cabbage leaves in it,
it looks and smells fantastic!
Hey everyone it's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com in Bangkok, Thailand
At the airport now and Ying and I are on our way to Incheon International Airport, Seoul, Korea
And we're gonna be there for the next seven days along with Ying's two sisters,
we're gonna be sightseeing and eating and I'm gonna be vlogging
And then after that we're gonna travel from Seoul to Jeonju, which is in kind of the South of South Korea
So stay tuned for lots of vlogs coming from Korea and lots of Korean food
Ying are you excited to go to Korea?/
Peace out!
Our flight leaves at a little after midnight at 12:10 and I think it should be about 6 hour flight,
we're gonna arrive early in the morning into Seoul
I fell asleep before we took off and it is now morning and they have just come around with breakfast
Oh, the hotdog is better than it looks!
We have just landed at Incheon International Airport,
Welcome to South Korea!
Oh that was some cold air!
It is 7:30 AM in the morning
That was a good flight with Korean Air!
Before we leave the airport, we just bought these little cards,
it's called T-Money, and you can use it for the subway, you can use it for the train,
you can use it for the bus, I think
And you can buy that T-Money card at any of the convenience stores,
there are a couple of them right here as you arrive in the airport
We just arrived to Seoul Station, that ride took about 1 hour,
we're gonna be staying at an airbnb that we rented, but we cannot check in until 3 pm
So it is now about 10 AM, we're gonna look for a locker,
so that we can walk around and then after that come back for our bags,
and then we'll check in later this afternoon
This is by far the most high-tech locker system I've ever seen in my life!
The entire block of lockers is all controlled throughout from this computer screen
So we'll take, I think we'll take this one
Oh, that's awesome! And it opens!
Success with the locker, i haven't really had a chance yet to do any research,
so we're just gonna walk around try to find something quick to eat
And then hopefully throughout today, I'll be able to do more research on where to eat and what to do
Oh! This is a good looking restaurant right here! I think this is where we're eating right here!
Yeah
All the menu is in Korean, but they had this one little printed off paper that was in English,
and it said that they serve potato and pork bone soup,
and they had all different sizes. We ordered the large size for all four of us
Oh, I gotta have a piece of kimchi right now
I love kimchi!
They are just entire cabbage leaves, kimchi cabbage leaves in it,
big pork bones, lots of potatoes, and a bunch of leaves on top. It looks and smells fantastic!
She gave us some scissors as well,
so I think we might chop up everything into bite sized pieces before we start eating
This is just a beautiful hot pot, there is so much kimchi in here, and just giant pork bones
Oh!
It's really good, that's like, that is like pork kimchi soup
You can taste a little bit of the sourness from all that kimchi,
and mostly it's just pretty porky!
And they're just gigantic bones in here, so I think there is not a whole lot of meat,
but there is a little bit of meat
And let me take some of that kimchi as well, put it onto my plate
Oh, I gotta eat some of that kimchi with rice
that is a lot of hot kimchi
Oh, that just slides off the bone, looks extraordinarily tender
and eat that with a piece of kimchi as well
That is so tender! You don't even need to chew, you don't need teeth for that meat
So that's just like the extremely tender result of boling pork for a very very long time
I actually forgot that potato is one of the main ingredients in this dish,
but there are some big chunks of potato, I think the potato has sort of,
parts of the potato have slightly disintegrated into the soup so that's kind of what's thickening it
I know this is kind of a little bit of starchiness in the soup along with that pepper, red chili broth
Let me take another bite and I want to have one of those leaves that was sitting on top,
I think that is one right there
That leaf has a wonderful slight liquorish flavor to it,
I think, I think it might be similar to shiso leaf or sesame leaf
Almost like a clove and liquorish anise flavor to it
They have a sauce on the table, I have no idea what it is, but I'm gonna try it
Kind of looks like it needs to be stirred up though because there is some different layers of ingredients in it
All right!
And let me taste some of this on a piece of kimchi with some rice
That's wasabi
Oh that's wonderful!
It's kind of like a sweet wasabi sauce
Oh that's good, that goes immediately up your nose!
I'm gonna put on a little bit of wasabi, oh yeah!
This has been outstandingly delicious, we're getting to the bottom of our pan here,
and look at how thick and how wonderful the broth is at the bottom,
I think that's a combination of some of the pork fat + some of the like collagen and marrow
that's come out of the bones from being boiled for so long and maybe a little bit of that potato
That is incredible! Oh,It is thick and hardy and rich, that is intensely flavorful!
That was a truly incredible first meal here in Seoul this trip
And this is a really good restaurant, it's basically right across the street from Seoul Station
Amazing, I'm feeling extremely good after that and that is one my favorite ways to
find restaurants just walking around and seeing a place that looks good
We're back at Seoul Station now, and it is cherry blossom season,
so Ying's sisters search for somewhere that is good for seeing the cherry blossoms,
we're on our way there now
We got off the subway at National Assembly and then took exit number 1,
and after such a good lunch, I'm really tired, so we're just gonna walk around here for a little bit,
and then probably head back to Seoul Station and by then it should be time for us to check in to our airbnb
They are blossoming in fully white-ish pink flowers covering the trees, it is really nice to walk through
Oh, and they have lots of snacks too like cotton candy and I smelled some grilled chicken back there as well
We made it back to Seoul Station, picked up our bags,
and we are walking around this area looking for our apartment
We had a little bit of an adventure as soon as we arrived, I was typing in the keypad the code,
and we were met by a couple of Seoul tourists police, and they said that this building
is not recognized or registered as a tourist lodging facility, it's a business building and an office building,
and so they said it doesn't have the proper insurance that it needs to house people especially tourists,
but the police were really nice and they gave us their numbers to make sure
we call them if anything bad happens, but we're here now and it's pretty nice
it's a big spacious room, and then there are two bedrooms and quite a few beds,
so it can accomodate a lot of people
I fell into a deep sleep for about an hour, just woke up, I kinda only feel about half alert right now,
but we're walking outside and looking for something to eat for dinner now
And they just looks like a nice friendly little place, but they have no English menu so we're just ordering of the photos
that they have here and we'll see what we ordered
to start off we got a whole pile of fried chicken, I think it's a whole chicken that's chopped off into pieces
and then deep fried to golden brown, it's because it smelled so good
and she told us to eat it with two different dipping sauces, one is just salt,
and then the other is like a chili looking sauce
I'm gonna try it with just a little bit of salt, so I get the full full fried chicken flavor potential
Wow!
That is unbelievably juicy!
I'm just absolutely gushing with chicken juices
and then that skin on the top and that brown golden layer is so crispy,
I love it with just that little bit of salt just to compliment it
It is a pretty good sized plate, and at first I thought they were noodles,
but I think they were just bean sprouts, yeah they're all bean sprouts,
are there any noodles down here?
I don't think so, but then just a mix of seafood, there is crab in here,
there are mussels, there are octopus,there is shrimp, and lots of green onions
and I think this is just like a blend of seafood, and bean sprouts, and chili
Grab one of those shrimp
They're very crisp and have that kind of an earthy taste to them
Actually I divided it in half and we just gonna eat the whole thing
A little bit chewy
I just got a bowl of the soup version now, I think it's all the same ingredients,
the bean sprouts, the shrimps, the mussels, all the same seafood,
but this is a soup instead of stir fried
Yeah, has that exact pretty much the same taste, except one is stir fried dry where this one is the soup
but this one has more of a shrimpy taste to it, it tastes like dry shrimp mixed with dry chilis
Another thing that I've noticed in both of these different dishes are these little things,
and I have no idea what they are, but they are very common in both of these dishes
scattered throughout both of them, I'm gonna try one
I don't even know if I know what just happened
It's really hard, I thought it was like a nut or seed, but then I bit harder,
and it just exploded with some kind of salty juice, a little bit seafoody,
and now, now it's just like a really very very rubbery texture, what is that? I think it's some kind of seafood
That was another great meal in Seoul, we're gonna walk over to the Seoul Station now,
and catch the subway to Myeong-dong, which is a big shopping district and
walk around there for a little while
There are lots and lots of clothes here and both indoor shops as well as a lot of street shopping as well,
you'll find all sort of things especially a lot of cosmetic stores and right now,
the girls went in to buy some cosmetics
I'm gonna go ahead and end the vlog for today right now, it has been a great day,
a really really long day that started last night coming from Bangkok
We arrived to Seoul, delicious food, I especially loved our first meal just walking into that random restaurant,
and having that pork bone rib kimchi soup, that was incredibly good!
Thank you all very much for watching this video, please remember to give it a thumbs up,
leave a comment below, make sure you subscribe for lots of videos, lots more food videos,
and I will see you for the next video!
Let me try one more
It feels like a hard nut or a sea..